[Music]  this reminds me of the spa back at the  hotel  really not at all  okay let's blast this [ __ ] whoa  whoa whoa  no you go in there guns blazing they're  gonna get trigger happy inside then it's  bye-bye darius  he asks for me he needs me so we're  gonna do this my way  that means no killing no guns and no  blood  boring is always best understood of  course not  [Music]  jesus christ  what have you done yeah a little bit too  fresh i specifically said  no killing i'm not on sabbatical where  is your shirt  you're asleep and hear the breeze  can you please wake the hell up  we are hiding in italia  [Applause]  when you push me by the boobs i could  hear the little boy inside of you mommy  please don't  die i don't think that's what i was  screaming  let's go do what we do and blow some  things up  take them to the doctor chambers what  you have separate torture children  mark my words  and here we go  where is your shirt hi  [Music]  foreign  [Music]